[Music]
how stoked are you for her I'm so stoked
for like the sexiest thing in the world
is someone who's strong and powerful and
funny and she's all those things so I'm
so happy and excited just to be in the
crowd like feel that energy when she
gets up there did you practice her
speech for you no no she's like been
super secretive about it so but I kind
of want that I want to be able to like
we were talking about like I want to go
into the crowd and like feel that energy
and feel all those all those women that
she's speaking to like to become
empowered by it so I kind of want to go
into it fresh as well you guys have been
doing a lot of LA to Nashville back and
forth is there a chance anyone's moving
to one coast and moving in with each
other I mean what's happening here you
and my mother or ask you that question I
like to be mature yeah I don't know
we'll see right now it's um it's been
nice cuz I have a lot of work out here
like we had an I heart thing last night
that I had to work so it's been kind of
easy to come back and forth so we'll see
what happens going forward my last
question for you we're so excited to see
Sarah up there to see her speak today
me too the thing is like everybody who
loves you loves that you have loves so
what is it about this relationship that
is just like working so well for you you
guys seem like you have so much fun
together
it's like when the two of the biggest
dorks collide and then make like one big
dork dork pie I guess I don't know I
don't I just this is nice
I don't know we I feel like we both
needed a win and we got one so
yeah that's I'm feeling again maternal
[Music]